hey screen junkies welcome to honest
trailer commentaries for the emoji movie
I'm Spencer J Gilbert with me as always
is Dan Merle hello
not with us this time but also working
with us as always as Joestar it hasn't
been on the last couple of episodes he's
been busy with other things that said he
is not dead and still an employee he is
still with us yes yeah no it's we've
been working with it's the holidays so
we've been working ahead and Joe has
been very diligently in the auction
trailer workshop cobbling together we're
all running around with our heads on
fire but he really dodged a bullet
because he doesn't have to talk about
the emoji movie anymore yeah Wow Dan
yeah I saw this when it came out in the
theater believe it or not how many
people it was a critic screening so it
was pretty full okay um yeah the thing
is it is the it is a really really
aggressively bland movie for me built
around the worst idea of all time yeah
just a truly horrific Lee cynically bad
idea I'm gonna give our viewers a heads
up this is bad
SEO CEO monetization right now but we
don't even have any deleted scenes for
this one it just all came out fully
formed in a little ball of hatred
so if you're waiting for that or if
you're waiting for some good to come
watching us talk about the emoji movie
yeah go learn a trade or you know read a
book something cuz this videos not gonna
change from here on out that being said
I hated this movie a lot more than you
did you did you hack this hate relive
like like a hairball it was in your
stomach it just came out of you fully
formed like I think Joe and I read it we
were just like we're not even gonna
rewrite this this is obviously very
personal for you so this is this is I
think I think we can say like 98% pure
spending it really yeah which I feel
like again honest trailers is doesn't
just exist to [ __ ] on a movie but
sometimes a film comes along that just
really does it really sticks in my craw
and this was it and and I think what I
weighed more than you did was like he
said it's the worst idea for a movie
was that they took just the most surface
level annoying
like what's popular right now idea for a
film and that was all they cared about
yeah they didn't have a story I almost
think that there is something
interesting that they could have done
that they made like a slight head fake
towards of like oh we're on our phones
too much like right people or people
only live their lives on here there's
maybe an opening for them to do
something smart with that no it is TJ
Miller and the carpool karaoke guy
farting their way through a dumb bland
world where nothing makes sense and they
just pull dumb jokes and dumb plot saves
out of their ass and then it ends
keeping in mind that when you say that
it's it is very much a movie about
what's popular right now the the right
now and that sentence is 2014 when the
movie had to be written in order for
this to be animated yes and never
updated no no there were no reshoots
three years ago yes put it out in 27 my
god there the amount of time they spend
playing candy crush is so appropriate
for 2014 and so inappropriate for 2017 I
just hated it I hated it I don't know
what to tell you beyond that I that I
couldn't stand it the rules make no
sense they set up this overly
complicated system for how emojis work
and it's this machine that moves around
and like it's a job to go it's so
[ __ ] stupid let's just run the
trailer but dude do the trailer this is
for murrs for ya
[Music]
Toy Story was visionary inside-out was a
true original and wreck-it Ralph was
still pretty good but now the secret
world under our own premise ends up like
Taco Bell through a human centipede in
the emoji movie experience of film this
run its course are we done with like oh
but these things are actually animated
and alive when you're not in the room oh
I hope so I mean we got a wreck-it Ralph
to common yeah where he goes onto the
internet which right maybe address this
but better ya know so at least they're
gonna try to advance that concept and we
have Toy Story 4 coming I think perhaps
new new movies about everyday items
being alive might be done yes maybe
sausage party killed it it's not that it
was bad but they just put the nail in
that coffin it was the in the way that
airplane put the nail in the disaster
movie coffin of the 70s perhaps sausage
party and this put the nail in the
coffin of these things have a mind of
their own
yeah oh uh let's see what we got
microphones we're not in the studio it's
Mikey yeah after JT's Ren adjust the
camera nice now it's a whole show that
happens that no one even sees behind the
camera it's wait yeah exactly
that said I I don't want to see any more
of these movies no if it's not Pixar I
don't want to see it at this point I
just don't trust anyone to do it well
yeah that's about right yeah Warner
Brothers animation Lego people although
Ninjago wasn't very good yeah I don't
even know anymore
it's keep it going custody of the kids
for a weekend where the underlying IP is
the top priority
while story plot character humor and
tone come tight for dead last in a film
that may not be the worst one ever made
but it is the worst example of Hollywood
farting out 80 minutes of cynical
branded advertising and pretending it's
a movie to honest here's only take might
be making 200 stink out of all this
Steudle emojis those little pictures
morons use instead of words that's not
fair I use emojis - but that's written
from a place of anger from having just
watch the emoji movie twice no I'm sorry
I only made it through it once and I had
to I had to do it yeah in a theater
again no it's it's changed the way I
text well-done emoji movie he got me to
stop using them yeah if they were alive
no how about with their day job is like
no their love life never will too bad
because you're going inside the bland
animated world of your phone whether you
like it or not full of three-dimensional
representations of two-dimensional text
IQ us with budgets for a second and back
it up to like a few frames to see that
hand pointing at like okay what the hell
is this Rube Goldberg ass operation that
they have going on there where to text a
giant hand takes a laser scan of an
emoji making a face like holding a face
of the time I'm just using a picture I
assume pictures exist well I think it's
making a pic taking a picture when you
can do so it's like the hand is an
extension of the users hand right
picking an emoji it's really it's also
okay so this is like their day job right
like they all come into work for the day
and they're and they wait for the thing
to pick them and they make the face and
then they leave aren't their shifts like
oh they're more is there only one at a
time like because he has parents right
so the met parents and he's taking over
for them so did they work the night
shift really working the day shift yeah
what are the because there are shifts
they go home at night so what happens
when you text then I hate this movie I
hate I hate the lack of thought gone
into it and I've thought about it more
than anyone ever should have to let's
keep going two-dimensional text icons
with one dimension to their
personalities and zero depth to any of
this
are you finished here's that jump a lot
VG the Mamo G voice bye humanity's own
mad TJ Miller also a little harsh in the
ocean travel from app to app to show up
all the cross-promotion sony was able to
sell but because internet culture moves
faster than it takes to animate a movie
all the apps are outdated it's like a
console or arcade thing you dance around
during it's stupid they just paid that
they sign the biggest check so just
dance it is alright yeah let's
NBD dude Oh shades and all the emojis
have notes it's Romans left until the
return to 9 hours for buying human emoji
Highbridge we've got a chicken okay
think of the laziest joke you can think
of in the nosebleeds I'm standing right
here
no even lazier what kind of business
monkey business now dumb it down to the
point where it barely makes sense
anymore does that the time Hey
reverse what can I curse on the show I
don't know anymore I don't think we're
discouraged from it yeah but what the
turd emoji is that joke are the hands
supposed to be boobs is that is that the
joke that like the joke would be that
the walk would be embarrassed that he's
looking at the hour and the minute rings
instead of his eyes the equivalent that
that looking at the hands of a clock
emoji is equivalent to inappropriately I
believe looking at someone's cleavage
which is a joke on so many levels
because the face of a clock yes are the
numbers in the hands yes that's like the
face so he's looking at the face of the
clock right
hands look nothing like boobs dad is
true the clock if if the clock is
fulfilling his function as a clock who I
assume goes about his day he would want
people to look at the time well that
that that is the yeah that's the
inherent contradiction and that joke is
that you're using the clock to its
designated function so it would be that
a clock is inherently offend offended by
you using it for its purpose
oh boy quickly no Spencer gonna make it
time hey congratulations
now you're writing the emoji movie
suffer through a parade of dumb kids
humor bordering on anti comedy where the
magic is running to the ground so hard
you can't tell what happiness is anymore
I'm just beaming yeah I thought this was
funny the first song time with cousin
they got Stephen right does in pan comic
I samara ever yeah oh that was the
trailers to stop i didn't say stop don't
overreact
i told you not to overreact please stop
his meds parents have a divorce in the
middle of this movie do they they split
up and not in like a like a literal like
you look over here i look over here like
their relationship falls apart because
he can't feel emotion for their son
anymore i missed that entire part of the
movie yeah no you're already dead you're
dead inside by then yeah yeah but yeah
they just slipped in I don't know maybe
whoever wrote it was going through
something at the time it's just like
they slide in this C story about his
parents going through a divorce because
their son ran away yeah cool cool emoji
movie real picked me up I was just I was
just thinking scream is on this guy's
phone there's like 40 apps on his home
screen like that's just bad app
management I gotta sell those spots man
Forex and sell themselves continue yeah
I get it
ah but nowhere does this comedy come
closer to tragedy than Sir Patrick
Stewart playing come on sir
are you doing proof that you can give a
man Talent Awards in a knighthood but
it's nothing compared to the power of a
paycheck
so do they agree to these things before
they read the script or do they just not
read the script or by the time they read
the script it's too late to back out
I get the sense that there was probably
no script
and you know they sell it as like it's
for kids see kids will love it
Sir Patrick you have kids he does have
kids but I think they're like adult kids
yeah it's like I don't I don't know what
the appeal was other than perhaps a nice
paycheck which TV don't pay that much
mm-hmm being a knight maybe I don't know
what that I mean I'm sure he's doing
fine okay but he's a Shakespearean actor
yes exactly is the value of a dollar and
if you get a chance to cash in why not
right I don't know I keep going Jack
you're so soft poop not too soft I hope
so experience the perfect film for our
times that doesn't teach you the
positive role of sadness like inside out
or turn a cash grab into something
insightful like the lego movie but
instead teaches children that life is a
meaningless mediocre joyless slob that
takes place mostly on your phone and
only exists to serve a global
conglomerates interest Oh
too honest again boob joke just doing my
duty
sorry the following actual quotes for
the reviews it's like I'm in good
company here you can play these quotes
this toxic piece of a lot of good people
probably had to work really hard on this
movie for a really long time so I'm
sorry not for anything I said about the
film just you know those Lost years of
your life yeah
yes yeah I can't imagine what it's like
because you're probably rushed and you
know like we talked about with the
Justice League like the director is
probably telling you what to do on this
and what do you do man
yeah go to the bank yeah and you buy
whatever makes you happy yeah I mean I
know that uh Disney animators hide sex
stuff these people probably hid cries
for help and their phone numbers
Oh help me please resumes that kind of
thing over time yeah yeah yeah not good
not not a good film probably my least
favorite movie of the year
Wow I'll put it above fifty shades a
darker for me Wow no and even the mummy
so yeah man I think it's only saving
graces it's not very long true and short
and short yep so neither will this video
be unless you have anything else to say
about the emotion you got nothing else
to say about the emoji movie or emoji in
general what's favorite app my favorite
app yeah I use Twitter the most I guess
yeah there you go and home escapes well
get ready for the Twitter movie and home
escapes the film's gifts you I'm
renovating a house Spencer really I'm in
the kitchen
more interesting to me then it's
extremely expensive and addictive and I
need help I have no idea are you talking
to your own house more it's a virtual
house that I you have to play levels
like candy crush to get stars in order
to earn renovations and I found that it
is extremely extremely extremely
habit-forming Wow and this is just
modern capitalism or what it's like to
be it our generation of like we can't
have homes but we can buy you can buy
renovate this mansion of fate a fake
house yeah that's pretty much it I love
it and also it is a real time suck so
just I try it I don't know what to say
well we I hope people got something out
of this video which is don't watch the
emoji movie and do check out homes
be ready that's an investment it's a
free app yeah but time isn't free but
yeah we'll be back next week with more
pics of Dan's dream house and our next
movie which is another terrible film but
one that we enjoyed a lot you'll see
what that means next week thanks for
watching guys
[Music]
you